nine juneteenth celebrations were held
across the country on sunday the new
federal holiday marks the end of slavery
here in the u.s the city of las vegas
held an early celebration in the arts
district saturday music food and vendors
from black-owned businesses
this is very something special for the
community you know us
rising up and celebrating together as
one as a whole
around the world we thought the wind was
going to hold us back but we're not
allowing that to hold us back and that
is significant for what today means it
means do not hold us back we are alive
and we are here we are thankful we're
happy for that
also downtown the discovery children's
museum hosted a juneteenth celebration
you see their governor steve ceslek
other local leaders there's a councilman
creer they took part as well the museum
hosted special dance performances and
juneteenth related workshops we'll look
at some more of the local celebrations
coming up in the next half hour of
course juneteenth is observed today so
you notice some government offices and
banks are closed
a pivotal